let's start today with some of Joe
Biden's recent accomplishments you know
on the bonus show today we'll be talking
about President Joe Biden's first
presidential veto that was ordered I'm
not going to do that now because we have
a plan to talk about it a little bit
later but as the former president seems
to be closer and closer to a criminal
indictment it's important not to lose
sight of the fact that without
controversy without drama without
drawing with a Sharpie on a hurricane
map or asking about nuking Europe or a
hurricane or whatever the case may be
Joe Biden has accomplished a bunch of
little things none of which individually
are completely mind-blowing but it's a
lot of little very important things let
me know if you find this interesting let
me know if you find this informative
here are some examples the FCC
is going to release some additional
funds this week to support What's called
the affordable connectivity program and
this is a program it's part of the
bipartisan infrastructure law that was
passed under Joe Biden and it will
provide households that are eligible
with a thirty dollar credit towards the
cost of their internet service plan or a
75 dollar monthly credit for households
living on tribal land towards their
internet service and so the idea here is
get more people Broadband the effect you
might say well how many people will that
help it'll help a bunch of people and
then it will it's expected to get
Broadband to 16 million households that
don't currently have it that's like five
percent of the United States that's a
really big deal not explode it's not a
new health care plan but it is a program
with a a measurable benefit that will
get something that is increasingly a
requirement how do you increasingly how
do you exist in the world
um and and Avail yourself of all of the
normal amenities that many of us take
for granted if you don't have broadband
internet well this will get 16 million
households broadband internet that's a
great thing the Department of Health and
Human Services HHS is releasing half a
billion dollars in low-income home
energy assistance funds and the idea
here is help people cover home heating
costs we've had inflation Energy prices
are high the Biden Administration in
November announced the distribution of a
bunch of this money and it is now
happening and it's getting a little bit
of a bump to help people pay for heating
this is a great thing again it doesn't
solve the problem that groceries are
expensive it doesn't deal with stagnant
wages but now we've got credits towards
broadband and funds for home heating
that's a really great thing then we go
to prescription drugs there are new
details on which Medicare Part B drugs
now remember if you get access to the
bonus show we recently talked about what
are these drugs Medicare Part B drugs
are expensive drugs administered by
doctors if the prices of certain drugs
go up faster than inflation there are
going to be funds to subsidize the cost
of those drugs back down does this fix
the problem of health care prices or
prescription drug costs no but it's
going to identify drugs that will be
qualified for inflation rebates or
excessive price increases when the price
of these drugs goes up above and beyond
the cost of inflation and so people who
benefit from these funds will see the
prices of these drugs to them lowered in
some cases significantly that's another
really great thing now we go to the EPA
where this it's really broad spectrum
stuff we go to the EPA the EPA has taken
step forward in delivering clean water
uh particularly to disadvantaged
communities by proposing some new
standards national standards for
drinking water contamination levels and
what what amounts of certain elements
are allowed to be there in terms of pfas
substances this is expected to prevent
thousands of deaths and Reduce by tens
of thousands the number of illnesses
attributable to those types of water
contaminants is it perfect no does it
fix everybody's water everywhere no it
certainly doesn't but is it a good thing
with a measurable impact yes it is uh
and then a couple other small things a
Department of Transportation is
launching its Community electric vehicle
charging program oh but not everybody
can afford electric vehicles right but
as we go towards affordability hopefully
one of the big impediments is having
infrastructure to charge your car where
you live and or work and the Department
of Transportation is launching that
that's a program that was previously put
in place but it is now launching and
then the department of energy is moving
forward with 750 million dollars for
clean hydrogen research now I know there
are people who say David hydrogen fuel
is not the future well it might be uh it
might not be the future for vehicles but
maybe it is elsewhere it's certainly
something that should be researched and
that money is now being made available
these are all modest changes that will
have measurable positive impacts for in
some cases thousands or tens of
thousands or with some of these bigger
programs even millions of people quietly
accomplishing things couple different
thoughts number one is this interesting
to people is it interesting to hear
about some of these things that are
happening number two
is there a disconnect between those who
benefit from these programs and making
the connection that oh this is because
either of the inflation reduction act or
because of other programs I like that
maybe I am more satisfied with Joe
Biden's job performance than I thought
and what I mean by that is very often
people are asked do you approve or not
of the job that the president is doing
and oftentimes people say I do or I
don't and very often it's driven by
what's in the news oh the Afghanistan
withdrawal went well or it didn't go
well I approve or I disapprove when you
would think if people were more aware of
some of these programs if you're now
getting 30 bucks a month towards
broadband and they're starting to build
charging stations near where you live
and you're getting home heating
assistance and a Medicare Part B drug is
now being subsidized for you that's
tangible stuff but only if you know
about it might it influence your level
of satisfaction with the job that Joe
Biden is doing so that's another aspect
to this let me know your thoughts do you
want to regularly hear these sorts of
updates curious to hear what people
think
as we wait to see
whether Donald Trump will be arrested
and indicted in New York we have new
news out of Georgia that there may be
potential racketeering and conspiracy
charges there coming against the failed
former president Donald Trump this is
again the belief about mounting legal
troubles without yet even knowing
whether the New York indictment is going
to happen now before I get into this CNN
report about what we have learned I want
to remind people that
one of the possibilities if and when the
New York indictment of trump comes down
which Trump said would be today
certainly not seeming like it's going to
be today but we will follow it
one of the reactions was it's kind of a
weak charge it's not the strongest
charge that could be made against Trump
and I agreed with that and the Hope was
that we know there have been prosecutors
who despite having great evidence
against Trump have been hesitant to be
the first to indict a sitting or former
president and that now a former
president is it possible that the Stormy
Daniels charges will break the levy and
then we will see other indictments come
in that's the hope and if that's the
case CNN reports that Georgia
prosecutors are considering racketeering
and conspiracy charges and this is all
related to Trump's effort to overturn
the results in Georgia in the 2020
election where of course Joe Biden won
because Joe Biden received more votes
CNN reports
Atlanta area prosecutors are considering
racketeering and conspiracy charges
Fulton County district attorney fani
Willis could make decisions on charges
this spring Willis will bring her
charging recommendations to the
regularly seated grand juries each
serving two-month terms two regular
grand juries were seated in March the
next batch will be sworn in in May
investigators have at least three
recordings of trump pressuring Georgia
officials including a phone call that he
made to the Georgia house speaker to
push for a special session to overturn
Democrat Joe Biden's 2020 Victory
there's also a recording of Trump's call
to a top investigator with the Georgia
Secretary of State's office where they
were looking into quashed allegations or
of irregularities with signature
matching and then of course Willis
kicked off the investigation soon after
the infamous January phone call wherein
Trump pressures Brad raffensberger to 5
find the votes necessary for him to win
this is the next layer mediaite also
reporting Trump's legal woes go from bad
to worse as CNN reports potential Ricoh
charges for pressuring Georgia election
officials so what do I believe is going
to happen I have no idea
as I've said for a long time I believe
indictments are plausible and prison
time is essentially an impossibility for
Donald Trump I've explained why numerous
times so I won't do it here this is very
serious stuff there's no doubt that
these are potentially very serious
charges at the same time many of you
like me have been stuck in this sort of
time Loop where we're always close to
possible charges possible charges
stemming from this or that blatant
violation of the law that we read about
and yet quote nothing happens on the one
hand I feel that frustration I share
that frustration and there is a feeling
that this is yet just never going to
happen on the other hand when you speak
to Legal experts they do say these
things take a while uh oftentimes when
you look at white-collar Crimes by
non-presidents just by you know a CEO of
a tech company or a banker or whatever
the case may be it can take years to
build these cases here we're talking
about a man who was and is now a former
sitting president and so the timeline is
not actually that unusual it's just that
in most cases we're not following
investigations and we're not aware of
possible charges until much closer to
when those charges are announced so I am
not really taking a position as to
whether I do or don't think any
particular indictment or charge or
arrest is going to happen Trump said he
was getting arrested today it doesn't
seem like it's happening and now the
discussion is about either tomorrow or
next week I don't know I remain
convinced convinced that Trump will
never see the inside of a prison cell
and the the big picture of that is that
at the very worst case if there were a
plea or a guilty verdict
and there were to be confinement uh
allocated or
assigned to trump it would be served as
home confinement I think that that is
the absolute worst case scenario but
we're not even at that step yet we are
now at the step of there are four at
least major investigations into Trump
will any of them lead to an indictment
or an arrest we may know within hours we
may know tomorrow we may know next week
but the big news from the last 24 hours
is whatever happens with this New York
Stormy Daniels hush money case it is not
the end of the line as Georgia I have
believed is the strongest case for a
while now and it seems as though the
most serious charges could indeed come
from there leave me a comment let me
know at this point in time in your heart
of hearts
what do you expect is coming
one of our sponsors today is Bond charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
pacman15 for 15 off the link is down
below
an increasingly desperate panicked and
unhinged failed former president Donald
Trump released a cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs
midnight video last night early this
morning wherein he calls all four
investigations into him just Democratic
left-wing bias in yet another sign that
he is both not only really scared but
very very disconnected from reality this
video was released through Rumble and
embedded on Troth Central here is Trump
very late at night claiming that the
weight of his massive
polling lead where did you think I was
going with that the weight and size of
his massive polling lead is forcing
desperate Democrats to try to charge him
of course ignoring the reality that
these investigations have been going on
for a long time before he was even a
candidate for 2024. let's take a look
these four horrible radical left
Democrat investigators by the way I I
know people seeing this are going to
write to me and say David how can you
not comment on the fact that it's not
even orange that Trump is anymore it's
almost like he he's he's painted himself
so dark that it doesn't even make any
sense and his lips look white and folks
I get it I get it but it's not the focus
here I get that he looks like a like a
reverse mime I guess we would say but
we're not focusing on that here
your all-time favorite President me
is just a continuation of the most
disgusting Witch Hunt in the history of
our country it's gone on forever with
Russia Russia Russia and Ukraine Ukraine
Ukraine and the holler hooks it's an
absolute disgrace what's going on they
even spied on my campaign of course
that's not true should I explain that
again I guess I'll briefly just be it's
been a while I just I if you know the
explanation I apologize the the
allegation from Trump is that they spied
on my campaign
what happened was that Trump's 2016
campaign was in touch with so many
suspected criminals who were themselves
under surveillance that when those
suspect suspected criminals would make
phone calls to people associated with
Trump
Trump's Associates Associates would
incidentally be surveilled because they
were talking to suspected criminals they
weren't spying on Trump's campaign
and remember this with all of the work
that they did on Mueller no collusion
that's what the answer was was all no
collusion whether it's the Mar-A-Lago
raid or the unselect committee hoax
the perfect Georgia phone caller was
absolutely perfect or the stormy horse
face Daniels extortion plot there it is
they're all sick
and its fake news our enemies are
desperate to stop us because they know
that we are the only ones who can stop
them and they know it very strongly and
they're looking at the polls where not
me but we are up by so much they can't
believe it is that true we'll look at
that we won twice and now we've got to
win a third time they know that we can
defeat them they know that we will
defeat them but they're not coming after
me they're coming after you right this
is a classic which is by trying to hold
me accountable for crimes for which
there is evidence
you are really being targeted it's like
no no no they're targeting you for the
things you allegedly did I'm just
standing in their way right and I always
will stand in their way thank you very
much that video released just after the
stroke of midnight early this morning
and of course this unhinged panicked and
desperate as ever all four
investigations are merely Democrats
going after Trump because the polls are
so great for Trump the truth is that the
polls are good for Trump they're not
absolutely fantastic and in fact Trump
does worse against Joe Biden than does
Ron DeSantis just for uh being thorough
if you look at some recent polls yes
there continue to be polls in which
Trump is doing very well in the
Republican primary but there are also
polls that are quite close
um and it really depends on which poll
you look at these are Republican primary
polls and Trump is winning depending on
the state or whether it's a general poll
anywhere from between 2 and 28 over Ron
DeSantis but these are not big surges
these are worth what the numbers of been
and then importantly if you look at the
general election
uh Biden against DeSantis versus Biden
against Trump Biden does better against
Trump in every one of these recent polls
so it's not really true that there's a
polling motivation to try to get Trump
out of the way if you are Democrats and
by the way Democrats justice department
Biden in D.C prosecutor D.A in New York
the Georgia these are all different
groups is the truth and just to say
these are just all Democrats is also not
accurate but the idea that Democrats
would be saying let's charge Trump to
get him out of the way why DeSantis does
better than trump it wouldn't make any
sense to try to do that Ron DeSantis
attempted to straddle Donald Trump and
Stormy Daniels I know it sounds weird
and it sounded weird to me too but he
did it he tried to straddle them when
asked about the looming alleged
indictment and arrest of Donald Trump
Trump for the potentially illegal hush
money payment made by Trump's lawyer
Michael Cohen to Stormy Daniels Ron
DeSantis tried to ride the fence he
tried to straddle them and both say that
there are politically motivated
prosecutors involved but also to attack
Trump for paying off uh I think he
refers to her as a as a porn star in
this video I have to tell you folks I
don't think this is going to get
DeSantis very far but take a listen from
the Florida standard uh we wanted to
know what your thoughts are on the
rumored Trump indictment and if you have
any role in it um if charges are brought
on him will you have any role of
extradition to New York
so I've seen rumor swirl I have not seen
any facts uh yet and so I don't know
what's going to happen but I do know
this the the Manhattan district attorney
is a Soros funded prosecutor okay so
he's on message in terms of what a lot
of the pro-trump people have been saying
which is George Soros is at the end of
the day behind this and this is
politically motivated so he's on one
side of the fence which is this is what
the Trump people have been saying but he
doesn't stop there he doesn't lose this
opportunity and so he like other Soros
funded prosecutors they weaponize their
office to impose a political agenda on
Society at the expense of the rule of
law and Public Safety he has downgraded
over 50 percent of the felonies to
misdemeanors he says he doesn't want to
even have jail time for the vast vast
majority of crimes and what we've seen
in Manhattan is we've seen the sky the
crime rate go up okay so remember he's
he's continuing with the Manhattan crime
rate ignore during the fact that many
republican-run cities including Oklahoma
City have higher violent crime rates so
so far this is like a totally Trump
answer but wait for it and we've seen
citizens become less safe and so you're
talking about this situation with and
look I don't know what goes into paying
hush money to a porn star to to secure
silence over some type of alleged Affair
I just I can't speak to that okay so now
he's taking the dig at Trump and this
really triggered Trump and it really
triggered Don Jr and we will get to that
but DeSantis now jumping a little bit to
the other side of the fence
but what I can speak to
is that if you have a prosecutor
who is ignoring crimes happening every
single day in his jurisdiction and he
chooses to go back many many years ago
to try to use something about porn star
hush money payments you know that's an
example of pursuing a political agenda
now of course the truth is Michael Cohen
went to prison over this and he did it
all in service of Donald Trump so it's
only logical that if Michael Cohen
committed a crime you at least need to
seriously look at whether Donald Trump
did as well but I have to tell you I
don't know that this is going to win too
much quite frankly for Ron DeSantis and
what I mean by that is this is some real
both side stuff trying to straddle the
fence but I don't know that it's going
to bring in anybody on either side
DeSantis had days to think about listen
at some point I'm going to be asked
about this what is it that I should say
and what he comes up with is Soros
and I'm not really going to get too
involved and I don't know anything about
paying porn stars I just don't know that
this is going to bring anybody to his
side and as we've talked about before
the sorrow stuff is basically at this
point code for Jews and globalists and
nefarious Elite cabal conspiracy
theories and he's jumping fully into
that and the people on the Republican in
the Republican party that don't like
that aren't going to be thrilled with
this but at the same time he goes after
Trump with the whole hush money porn
star thing which many Trump supporters
have not exactly been thrilled about
acknowledging so DeSantis doesn't have
to approach it this way but he chooses
to he doesn't by the way mention no I
wouldn't get involved in extraditing
Trump to New York if it came to it I
don't believe it will and it's not going
to be something that comes up but the
Santa's opting not to even answer that
and I don't think that this is really
going to help DeSantis in any way it's
it's quite frankly he's trying to play
Both Sides in ways that both sides will
ultimately end up being turned off by
that's my view if you think this
approach by DeSantis makes any sense in
Hell let me know I'm curious to hear
from you Donald Trump also now hitting
back at Ron DeSantis and going with an
attempted homophobic smear suggesting
that Ron DeSantis may be gay yes it is
March of 2023 and this is where we are
Donald Trump apparently out of ideas
going with it's possible that DeSantis
might be into men rather than into women
I I don't I know it's crazy I know it's
crazy
um Donald Trump posting to truth social
in response to desantis's recent
statements about the Trump looming
indictment which we just looked at quote
Rhonda sanctimonious will probably find
out about false accusations and fake
stories sometime in the future as he
gets older wiser and better known when
he's unfairly and illegally attacked by
a woman even classmates that are
underage or possibly a man I'm sure he
will want to fight these Misfits just
like I do and again this is only a smear
to homophobic people right if I found
out a candidate I liked or was thinking
about supporting Were Gay I would say oh
I don't care about that what are their
policies but to a group of people that
would immediately not consider voting
for a candidate that was gay or might be
gay suggesting that there may be Men Who
come out of the woodwork is a smear now
when you look at the exact language of
it it sort of seems like Trump would be
saying well these would be false
allegations against DeSantis but still
it's that idea that with DeSantis it
might be Men Who come out of the
woodwork and then following up on this
attack with another attract attack on
Truth social
quote Ron de sanctimonious is dropping
in the polls so fast that he soon may be
falling behind young Vivek ramaswamy
people are beginning to find out that
Ron wanted to destroy Social Security
and raise its minimum age to at least
70. he also had strong plans for cutting
Medicare and still does nothing good
happens when you are a disciple of super
Rhino Paul Ryan also Florida did great
long before desanctus came along got my
coveted capital E endorsement shot up
like a rocket and won and of course I
won't look at the polls a second time
with you because we just looked at them
in a recent segment but it is not true
that DeSantis is falling in the polls
DeSantis is doing roughly just as well
as he has been doing he does better
against Trump in head-to-head matchups
DeSantis doing worse against Trump when
you include Nikki Haley and a whole
bunch of other people that might run for
that Republican nomination so this is a
full-blown Civil War right now Trump
with a looming arrest going after
DeSantis DeSantis going after Trump and
later what you will see is Don Jr's
involvement in this but that is going to
be much later today we're going to take
a short break and next I want to look at
this is really something else our
friends from the good Liars Jason and
davram
they went to the Lower Manhattan quote
protest yesterday against Trump's arrest
they were interviewed by right side
broadcasting network and it is the stuff
of Legends so we're going to look at
that after a quick break
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
this is absolutely the best I hope you
enjoy this so yesterday there was a
protest or a rally in lower Manhattan
near where presumably Donald Trump would
be arrested and booked if indeed that
happens right side broadcasting was
covering it live we covered it live and
it was just a complete and total mess
barely anybody showed up there seemed to
be more media than there were actual
protesters it was wild right side
broadcasting is doing interviews and
while right side broadcasting is
interviewing a young guy draped in some
kind of flag wearing a red Maga hat
Jason from the good liars which is this
satirical left-wing comedy duo they've
done really really good stuff in the
past
slowly Jason from the good Liars who if
you're watching right now you see is
sort of like screen right Jason drifts
into the shot
and the kid who's being interviewed
immediately recognizes Jason and says oh
the good liars the interviewer from
right side broadcasting apparently
doesn't know what the good liars is who
they are doesn't recognize Jason and
Jason just brutally trolls the the
protest was totally flaccid and I know
that technically it the word is
pronounced flaccid but nobody says it
that way so I'm going to continue saying
flaccid so people know it was like a wet
noodle protest totally pathetic Jason
slips in and it's just you have to see
the execution here let's take a look
demeanors and some misdemeanors to
felonies and a specifically Prosecuting
Donald Trump when he didn't he did very
little wrong if anything he's
prostituting around the city right now I
mean there's crime everywhere
so the kid immediately recognizes him
and says hey the good liar is what's up
and Jason just tries to shake his hand
and keep going the interviewer has no
clue what's going on and this this is
just so well done
there's crime everywhere and I'm think
like this is a political prosecution it
it has to be right like that's that's
the only way
it could be happening right now is that
they're going after a political
politically the only other option is
that Donald Trump lost by seven million
votes and is a loser who can't deal with
the fact that he he lost the election
because he based his whole personality
on being a winner and calling people
losers uh so so as you think his
attitude his approach his personality is
what is is what got us in this mess in
the first place potentially or I'm just
gonna choose to believe that the
election was stolen and everything that
he says the interviewer has no idea
what's going on because I kind of like
first based my whole personality on
supporting Donald Trump so I'm not gonna
maybe accept the option you live in you
live in the city I live in the city yeah
so how's the city changed over the last
couple years here I mean I know crime
but I don't live here so I don't I can't
judge what that goes it's gone up or
down yeah the New York City I think is
maybe 59th in in crime right now I think
there's four cities in Indiana uh that
has have more crime statistically than
and the kid next to Jason who's really a
Maga guy knows exactly what's going on
but he's allowing this to continue which
is just amazing work does yeah exactly
so I haven't really noticed a lot of
crime but I do see it on on you know Fox
News they say it's it's much more
dangerous now I don't I haven't seen it
I haven't seen any more crime so like
maybe that's it might not be true but I
I'm gonna choose to believe that it is
true because I I did see that on Fox
news of course because wherever you see
on Fox News is true right yeah just like
CNN and MSNBC if you see it on if you've
seen on cable news it's got to be true
Donald Trump says CNN and MSNBC are fake
news that's right we got to use the
Frank news okay yep okay so and then
just one more clip here and this is just
so brilliantly then
um he's asked to weigh in about like the
size of the of the rally and he also
slips in some good stuff here so I'm
I mean before I mean there's a lot of
people out here
it's like there's a lot of media
I would say just is basically all media
and I guess there's uh Brett is it
Braxton there's Braxton and then I see
another guy with the fight it seems like
there's about 10 Trump supporters here
but mostly the rest area media yeah so
oh man this is just absolutely fantastic
and uh you know the other the other
really funny thing in general about this
is that the Trump sort of like asked
supporters to be ready to protest or
whatever the case may be they're not
seeming like that willing to do it
interestingly enough except a few did go
out front to Trump Tower and I think
it's quite literally five people and a
woman blows a shofar
[Music]
so there are one two three four I guess
five or six people two holding Trump one
signs and one woman blows a shofar and
that's what they were able to sort of
coalesce at Trump Tower this is starting
to become surreal as if it hasn't been
surreal for the last six days it is
unbelievable what is going on here and
that's not even counting what Donald
Trump Jr's last 24 hours look like in
his first podcast episode
since we learned that at least Donald
Trump thinks he's about to get arrested
Donald Trump Jr delivered
a manic episode seemingly about what is
happening with his dad I've never seen
Junior like this and I've seen Junior
pretty hopped up he also seems to have
developed like a new accent for his
podcast where he speaks in an
extraordinarily strange way and his show
is called triggered which is very very
uh apropos of his demeanor here take a
look at this who really gives a crap
about law when you're a weapon
your office in a leftist state and where
everyone there agrees with you most of
the process ORS there don't know what
know what radical of the radical left
isn't this the most bizarre delivery
realize that it's insane fairness like
isn't she like paying his legal bills or
something like that
I don't know but you know the district
attorney is going to district attorney
right the Soros funded District
Attorneys are gonna do whatever the guy
that's Bank rolling them wants them to
do the law be damned the Constitution be
damned your rights be Dan because you
know when you hate America what
difference does it make this prosecution
isn't based on facts or the law or
anything that even resembles that it's
how would he know that pure Bolshevik
style witch hunter the hot take on
Twitter was that these guys are trying
to do this this was the hot stupid take
on Twitter over the weekend like the
dumbest take ever that they're trying to
do this to make sure it trumps the
nominee like they weren't trying to put
him in jail for the last eight years
like they didn't accuse me and the rest
of my family of treason and other things
okay and then at another moment I guess
ostensibly Junior on this episode was
interviewing Ronnie Jackson the
Republican congressman who used to be
Trump's doctor and again it's like it's
not really an interview because junior
is just ranting uncontrollably you know
as you know I had a really good
relationship with a lot of guys on my
secret service detail like so much so
that they moved guys off of my detail
because they were like oh you're too
comfortable with this I was like I
promise you guys like you want me
comfortable with my guys because if
something goes wrong like I I'm the guy
that thinks I'm always right like I get
that like I want to like the guy because
I'll trust him a lot everybody knew you
had more guns anyway yeah we won't even
get into that one clearly uh clearly so
you know we had a good time but you know
the one sort of thing and you know four
years of you know guys rotating in and
out I mean that was the one thing they
said with you you know you took care of
those guys too uh you know when they
were going on International trips when
they were pulling multiple day type
understand that what Junior is doing now
is saying Ronnie Jackson as Trump's
doctor would give sleeping medication to
Secret Service agents that that's really
the the core of what he is praising him
for here Snyder's you were the guy that
took care of everything that they ever
needed and did so so professionally uh
those guys love you yeah and you know
that stuff means so much more to me than
if the boss likes you right you know
when the guys they you know you could
blow off right you know I don't need to
pay attention yeah he's the lowly
whatever he's not high up on the totem
pole he can't help my promotion or my
career right you know when those guys
are a huge fan you know that's when I'm
like okay yeah now I I respect it so
much more and so watching that attack on
you right again a rear Admiral uh
obviously served in the Navy just a
bizarre bizarre show all together and
maybe the most interesting thing about
the Don Jr show on Rumble is that it in
the last three to five days has taken a
decidedly anti-run DeSantis perspective
and that's what I want to briefly look
at next apparently taking a cue from
Donald Trump starting the homophobic
attacks on Ron DeSantis Donald Trump Jr
now went on another one of these manic
rants this time targeted at Ron DeSantis
and he basically says DeSantis is
terrible in every way that the DeSantis
you think might exist from TV reports
doesn't really exist this is getting
very ugly and it's only going to get
worse
take a look
that's what it is guys he's owned by the
billionaire donors 100
controlled opposition let's see which
way the wind is blowing let's see which
way they want me to respond and I will
do it so I was hoping for a strong
response but we got a milk toast
response we got weaker than most Rhino
Republicans we got a weaker response
than a lot of never Trump Republicans
and guys
here's the deal
you can hire influencers to post videos
of you dunking on what was like a hot
Twitter take 10 days ago on some more on
local reporter you can get plenty of
people to do that as Ron has
but that doesn't make you ready for the
big leagues if you can't understand that
this is a fundamental issue of our time
then you're not ready then it's not your
time as even people like Mike cernovich
who have been big DeSantis supporters
just heartbroken that DeSantis doesn't
understand what Soros DA's and the
Bolsheviks are going to do to this
country the Bolsheviks can you imagine
listen to this guy he also said to
scientists blew it today the only people
saying otherwise personally hate Trump
or were never Trump in 16. and again
even some of those are coming out and
not just coming out like milk toast
they're coming out significantly
stronger than Governor DeSantis okay
again I know when you're ready for the
big leaves I've spent a lot of time with
these guys I spent a lot of time with
this and just personally the image
created online by the paid influencers
guys unfortunately one-on-one it doesn't
exist and this week made it clear so the
best and most accurate sign
that the Trump team sees DeSantis as a
real threat
is the amount of attention they have
paid to Ron DeSantis over the last two
weeks in particular
Trump posting daily on Troth Central
about Ron DeSantis Trump starting with
the homophobic smears against Ron
DeSantis Don Jr starting with the
attacks on Ron DeSantis uh people
associated with Trump including Steve
Bannon uh Mike pillow and others going
after Ron DeSantis you go after those
that you believe believe pose a threat
to you this is why Trump seemingly
encouraged Nikki Haley to run as far as
we know and is Going Bonkers attacking
Ron DeSantis he sees him as a threat
even though I still think it's important
to remember Trump is in a position of
power in the Republican primary if and
when the indictments come we will
evaluate how that changes those
prospects but if nothing changes this
really is Trump's nomination to lose
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
let's have a little fun here a unit
before we get to some serious stuff you
know that one of my favorite things if
you watch my live streams is When Donald
Trump has technical problems with his
audio and it actually happens a lot and
our incredible all these people don't
know what the hell they're doing further
scream that his days are numbers
[Music]
deal that included the largest
agricultural
there's worse of our farm product okay
but I think Eric they're not like they
lived up I used to check it every week
are they buying are they buying Okay so
yesterday apparently in the middle of
thinking he's very close to getting
arrested Donald Trump called in to some
pastors for Trump show I don't even know
how he gets booked on this stuff to be
totally honest and it's all really weird
and about 50 seconds in when they ask
him for a prayer call the audio just
goes completely crazy and then Trump
claims that the radical left-hacked him
it's let's just listen
and we are ready to introduce the
president of the United States by the
way the pr the president I thought the
president of the United States is Joe
Biden isn't it Donald J Trump is coming
on live with us the 45th and going to be
the 47th president of the United States
of America president Trump welcome to
pastors for Trump National Prayer call
for you how are you doing sir I'm doing
well Jackson I appreciate it and it's an
honor to be with you and I just heard a
great General Flynn and my friend Rogers
so we already have the echo but this is
nothing compared to what happens I was
very honored to give them full pardons
because they were treated horribly by
government these radical left lunatics
and uh full Gardens they're almost as
clean as you are right now Jackson
category okay but uh they're two
terrific people that really suffered
greatly at the hands of crazy people so
this was my uh my great honor and Clay
thank you very much for the great job
you've done at Kristin Davis we
appreciate it very much very much but
president Trump I wanted to uh tell you
I I was in my my wife and I were
attending the NCAA wrestling event in
Tulsa Oklahoma and we can see you and
all I could say is that my wife and I
Pastor Jackson everybody out there is
praying for you and I think a lot of
people are looking for a specific uh sir
um what is the prayer that you would
like for the thousands of pastors who
are tuning in right now what are the
specific prayer requests that you have
tonight sir
hmm
this is all still live remember
they can't hear that
that's Trump's saying they can't hear
that
somebody's working on something
very very important stuff here
some people thought maybe Trump got
arrested and that's why he went quiet
but that was seemingly not the case
uh
but more Trump whispering
one of the hosts gives a thumbs up
and they're getting very very close here
to fixing the audio
it's not even really clear what the
problem is because you can hear Trump
kind of breathing in the background
strangely enough
they may not have prayed hard enough for
the audio anyway
everybody's getting upset now
can you imagine waiting all day for your
interview with Trump and then this
happens
okay I guess we have a little phone
miscommunication and I think what
happened is the radical left we can hear
him the radical left was working on the
phone there's no question about it but I
think you heard what I said previously
is that right fellas
hello
okay anyway uh that that's basically
enough now there were people there were
people who wrote to me and said the
reason this happened is because Trump
doesn't like to answer religious
questions right remember this you
mentioned the Bible you've been talking
about how it's your favorite book and
you said I think last night in Iowa some
people are surprised that you say that
I'm wondering what one or two of your
most favored Bible uh verses are I
wouldn't want to get into it because to
me that's very personal you know when I
talk about the Bible it's very personal
so I don't want to get into it I don't
want to get into it it means a lot to
you that you think about our sight the
Bible means a lot to me but I don't want
to get into specifics all right so
anyway I actually don't think that's
what happened I think that was genuine
Tech trouble and I loved absolutely
every second of it a Fox News host is
unable to Define woke saying woke might
just be a feeling or a sense that you
get this coming from the people who say
if you can't Define woman right now
then you're some kind of
post-modernist wokeest from the
wokocracy of wokeestan here is Dana
Perino
and this has come up before
when you say woke and your anti-woke
what do you mean what is woke and we see
it backfire time and time again of
course the reason is that it's been
completely perverted by the right if you
want to talk about a loosey-goosey
post-modern explanation of woke listen
to Dana Perino yesterday on Fox News one
of the things about woke is
when President Trump was running and it
was before he won in in 2016. he used to
get standing ovations initially when he
would say political correctness is
ruining our country
and everybody that was clapping knew
exactly what he meant no they didn't see
that's the thing
people clap at Trump rallies without
understanding anything that's going on
this is Dana Perino's first mistake the
you know it when you see it everybody in
the crowd knew what political
correctness was even though Trump didn't
Define it no they don't they're like
trained seals they clap at anything but
it's sort of like the Supreme Court
definition of pornography you know it
when you see it so the Democrats want to
get you in an argument where you're
having to find defined wokeism as if the
Webster's Dictionary is defining it sort
of like you want to get into discussions
with people as if the definition of
woman is what you find in a 50 year old
version of the Webster's it's the exact
same thing the criticism they are making
is the one that many on the left make of
them when it comes to the term woman the
difference being the difference being
woke is a term that's been perverted
deliberately by these folks and that's
not what it is it is all it it could be
a feeling it could be a sense and I
wonder if Republican or conservatives
are going to have to Define it more she
could be right I don't know this this
will be yeah woke could just be a
feeling it could be a it could be a
little tingle down your leg Dana
is wokeism in the room with you right
now where exactly is it this is so
pathetic they say facts don't care about
your feelings and why can't you just
Define what you're talking about if the
wokeness they claim to be so widespread
so noticeable so prominent is nothing
more than a sense what you need a Ouija
board in order to figure out where it is
this is why these people are pathetic
when you actually try to engage them in
good faith about well listen when we
talk about women there's a difference
when we say what is a woman from the
purposes for the purposes of an
obstetrician versus what is a woman when
we're talking about how bathrooms or
Sports should be organized they don't
want to oh no no no that's that's
post-modern nonsense okay like what's
woke well I can't tell you it might just
be a feeling it's a feelings in my in my
arm I can feel the wokeness in my arm
give me a break guys but of course the
hypocrisy doesn't matter we're never
gonna win just by pointing out that they
are hypocrites and so we've got to find
another way forward radical repugnant
Republican congresswoman Lauren bobert
bizarrely was praying in the Capital
rotunda now as many of you know I am not
a Christian so I've wondered for a long
time when people say they were pleading
the blood of Jesus what the hell does
that mean
I'm wondering is this video
Lauren bobert pleading the blood of
Jesus you tell me what's going on here
take a look
oh blood of Jesus is only that blood
that grants us access into the holy of
holies into your presence God we thank
you so much for your goodness it is your
goodness that leads men to repentance
that causes men to change their mind
about you God
a different side of your Holiness yeah
God we love you because you first loved
us Jesus thank you for your Redemptive
work it was complete it was whole there
was nothing missing there was nothing
lacking there's nothing that you left
out Jesus
[Music]
the price for each and every one of us
you went to hell in our place
and you Rose again Victorious and when
you were seated at the right hand of the
father on high you did not leave us
alone how is this not mental illness
[Music]
foreign
I think you get the idea nothing makes
me respect religious people less than
when they orchestrate conspicuous public
prayers for publicity genuinely and by
the way listen I don't care what Matthew
says but in Matthew 6 6 it does say when
you pray go into your room close the
door and pray to your father who is
unseen
then your father who sees what is done
in secret will reward you not that I
care what is in Matthew 6 6 but if
Lauren bobert claims to shouldn't she be
following that dictate and not
orchestrating this pathetic public stunt
anyway is that pleading the blood of
Jesus maybe somebody can tell me what it
is we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to David P
I'm gonna play a voicemail for you from
a caller who is very agitated but this
doesn't seem to be a right winger
attacking me although they are attacking
me but not from a right-wing perspective
this is someone who apparently expects a
trump dictatorship
and is worried that I'm going to press
the fu button on them which I don't know
what that is maybe it means that we have
to bleep voicemails I'm not sure so dude
I really you push the fu button on me
because I was on a rant no you're making
money on this too you love talking about
this this is uh this is disgusting
what's going on you realize nothing's
gonna happen to this guy so hit the fu
button yeah get do it who now can look
what's good our current we're going to
be under dictatorship by Donald Trump
and his disgusting skank hold daughter
in this song oof who watch and see what
happens goodbye before you hit the fu
button well if there's no f-bombs
there's no reason to hit the fu button
which I don't have the fu button is like
Pat bleeping stuff so listen this guy's
pessimistic I get it I get I say I I
don't you know the the whole skank hole
thing as a way to reference to Ivanka
I'm not big on that but I sympathize
with the um sentiment that nothing's
going to happen and you know supposedly
Trump's arrest was today and I kept
saying this is what Trump claims we
don't know that that's the case it
doesn't seem as though that's happening
although maybe by the time we publish
this episode Trump will have been cuffed
and booked but I I doubt it
um I sympathize with this feeling that
nothing is going to be done
Trump won't be held accountable and he
will end up back in power with his
authoritarian delusions and dreams I
hope that that isn't the case but I
sympathize with the frustration on
today's bonus show we will talk about
President Joe Biden issuing his first
veto what was the veto over and what are
the implications we will discuss it
secondly Paris is increasingly under the
weight of stinky trash uncollected trash
has mounted to ten thousand tons because
of strikes that are going on and as a
result I am canceling my trip to Paris
scheduled for two weeks from now no I I
had a tentative visit to Paris when I'm
going to be in in Europe in a few weeks
but for other reasons it's not happening
it has nothing to do with the trash and
thirdly North Carolina
is urging the Supreme Court to throw out
a major elections case this is a case
we've talked about before this is a case
our bonus show audience will be familiar
with and it is a very consequential case
we will talk about why North Carolina is
saying to the Supreme Court throw it in
the trash flush it down the toilet 10 to
15 times all of those stories and more
will be discussed today
when producer Pat joins me on the bonus
show we do a bonus show every single day
every weekday every day that there's a
show if you want access to the bonus
show simply sign up at joinpakman.com
and if you would like access but
the financial commitment is too much for
you at this time you can request a free
membership at the following URL
David packman
.com
slash free membership don't email me
about it okay sign up to get a free
membership at davidpackman.com
membership I'll see you on the bonus
show otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow